maybe everybody thinks i'm all this and
i'm the number one guy whatever
at this level but me what's wrong with
me feeling like
i'm even better than what y'all are
saying you know what i'm saying leads to
the run-out for cunningham
hey cunningham well there's that grace
and fluidity here's cunningham just
nice footwork and that one bounce stop
and pop
gabe cunningham rises and rips
first question i had to ask for you and
i saw this going through it doing a
little research
and you bragged about it a little bit
and i need one myself too
but i need to know the story how you
started to cut hair
and how that all started and how many
cuts can you do
so go ahead just just run it run through
it for me please listen
so um i'd say it started
probably 7th grade
it's safe it was probably a little bit
earlier than that but seventh grade is
safe
um yeah it started uh me and my homeboys
we needed
we needed cuts nobody tried to pay that
20 every time especially in seventh
grade
uh yeah i was trying to get some weight
on my own so i started cutting hair
and i was horrible at first and shout
out to my homeboys they
they they had a fight for me because it
was some bad cuts early on
i'm saying now i'm saying you know how
you know how to cut then
it's just like riding the bike once you
learn it it just applies
so i can do all the cuts now i know how
to fade i don't know how to do all that
i don't do design
designs not me i can ask you the little
zigzag and all that okay nah you ain't
doing it
the funny thing is one of the things
there's a constant with every game i'm
watching and looking for and throughout
the whole season we watched you
i said this man never missed a moment of
of you weren't you never slept there was
always a cut you always
made sure it was clean it was never a
game i caught you slipping so i got to
give you that
long season listen the final long game
on tv and maybe throughout my whole life
ever since i learned how to cut
it just applies i'm telling you like i'm
going every before every game i'm in the
bathroom with it
where do you think this um this
confidence and maturity and
and uh like where did it start form with
you like where did you think
that it came from and how is it
instilled in you um
i think the biggest thing like i've i've
been blessed to have people
in my life that have tried these things
before me
yeah i'm saying and and were willing to
give me their knowledge about it
and i think the best thing i did growing
up was just listening to people older
having a big brother that was you know
in college tried overseas
um my dad he went to college and had an
injury
that ended his planned career so it's
been different things i've been able to
see and hear about
growing up that you know i just tried to
apply it to me and
and i've been blessed to be able to you
know make it to this point without any
any fault so
yeah i try to just keep a level head
like you know it's
it's i've seen my dad is you know
a perfect example of somebody that you
know had it going and then
everything went away so you know it's
having somebody like that as the head of
the household
you know raising just i'm blessed to
have that for sure man
you know he will have it right you know
you think about you know mom
pops and everybody like that like did
how much does it mean like what's the
motivation
having them supporting you like they are
now
uh to keep going further yes
i mean it's everything they've they've
been here since you know the first game
you know i'm saying and before that so
um you know having people that you know
really know you
and and you know care about you outside
of the game
is important and and it definitely
drives me i got my daughter riley she
you know i'm saying she's growing up
that's even more motivation for me so
um it's exciting for sure i'm excited
for it yeah how is
speak about riley like how has
fatherhood been for you
and then also how is it you know what
who is the father
that you envision yourself to be like
you're striving to be as well
i think the biggest thing is is
instilling confidence but like
it's hard to word it i don't want to
teach my my daughter happiness
you know i'm saying like like i don't
want to feel like you know everything is
always
all jolly like you know i'm saying
everything's going to make you
everything's going to be the way you
want it to be i feel like you know
teaching people right and wrong and and
you know making people fight through
adversity and things like that
make people work for you know a reward
and things like that you know those are
the things that
i'm excited to do like i have a problem
saying no to her already
so finding these type of things to do
for her it's gonna be tough for her
because i would have fired everything
already off the rip so yeah it's tough
for sure where was the moment that you
remember
like yo i i fell in love with basketball
like i really want to do this this is
what i'm committed to doing
i'd say probably going into ninth grade
is when
it all clicked like eighth grade is was
the last time that
i played football um and football
football was tough just because
like i love football but i love playing
games
for football like i'm not trying to get
out in that texas song
eventually i dropped football and then
my love basketball
double tripled all that it brings me to
another point too because you talked
about
coming into last season you know sort of
feeling like
you were a little bit overlooked in a
way which i know
may throw some people off because if
they look at my dress
but you're you're speaking to something
else can you talk about that too
right and i seen i've seen people saying
like
like bro you're already number one and
people have to realize like it's all
about perspective though at the same
time so like
like okay i i always want to play at
humble though you know what i'm saying
like i'm never
but maybe maybe everybody thinks i'm all
this and
i'm the number one guy whatever at this
level but me what's wrong with me
feeling like
i'm even better than what y'all was
saying you know what i'm saying like i
wanted to get to a point where
people watch full games of okay just
because they know like yeah he's one of
one
and it's not just cutting on a little
highlight tape you know i'm saying so
yeah yeah i still felt like i was
underrated just because i didn't
really have people's attention people
just kind of knew who i was
i mean it's also like your ability to
want to be coached right like
uh your high school coaches have said
that too it's just like accepting
criticism right i mean you you hear that
from
um like the tim duncan's and all the
other of the
the greats that they didn't mind being
coached
um was there for you like how did that
also become like
comfortable with taking criticism from
you know coaches trainers whatever it is
of just like yo this is the best for you
we're looking out for you like how did
that you get comfortable with taking
criticism as well
yeah i it started because my my fam like
my
my brother and sister they'll tell me
off the rip like
if i if there's anything wrong just with
anything in life so
if you are always hearing that from now
like whenever i hear from somebody else
you know
outside i'm not i'm not going to put too
much weight on it just because you know
it's normal to me i've been blessed to
have big time coaches like
coach budd and my bird like he's the
real deal i
i don't think there's ever been a better
high school person what he is so to have
somebody like him
you know like he's not afraid to coach
anybody he just wants what's best for
he's trying to you know make
real connections with you and help you
um you know it's easy to it's easier to
get coached by guys after that
coach mike at osu um he was more like a
just somebody that was like a big
brother in the coaches road like
you could talk to him about anything you
connect with him if you don't like
something you can tell him he's gonna
see what what he can do to fix it but he
always maintain leadership and
having guys like that around you know
growing up with coaches like that
it's like it's easy for me to get
coaches because i've been coached by
good coaches
where else any part of your game are you
like proud that you've seen the
development and growth um
last couple years it can be you can take
it back how far you want but
where are you really probably you've
made a lot of improvement in definitely
my
my jump shot for sure i feel like that's
probably
the the loudest point where like you
know that's probably the main one that
pops out of the screen like oh he's soon
a lot better now but
it's been fun you know just being able
to to grow into
more and more of a primary ball handler
and creator
um and i feel like that's the thing that
i think i've had the most fun with and
enjoyed the most
about like this whole journey getting to
this point is like
seeing myself go from somebody that was
you know a real life road guy
and just trying to you know set good
screens and
rebounds and get us you know just just
do all the right plays to
turn into the guy where like you know
what i'm saying i'm trying to make every
play now and
and i'm trying you know it the the
responsibility just grew
more and more so that's thing that you
know
i've been the most excited about and i'm
excited to see how it looks
going forward you know in the nba and
just seeing how that grows for sure
so i'm trying to be that dude i want to
be the best
point guard if they list me as a point
guard of all time the best whatever you
want
cunningham spins with the left hand how
pretty was that
watch the form perfect follow through
[Applause]
cunningham running one-hander you
leaving from you know local high school
and going to mount vern
like that's a sacrifice in a sense right
because you're leaving everything you've
known to go someone you're not
so i mean to that point even like can
you talk about
the sacrifices that you've made along
this basketball journey to get to this
point now
man i think that was probably the first
big one was
was leaving bowie to go to my birth like
man it's so crazy when i get out there
so it's my junior year when i get out
there
um i'm 16
and i turn 17 like couple month or a
couple weeks in so
leaving everybody everybody you ever
known like this is the first time
i haven't been around anybody there's
nobody in the whole state that
i know so i'm kind of just going into
this situation just hoping for the best
and mind you this was so crazy a lot of
people probably want to lead us coach
boyle had never even seen me play
basketball in person before i got there
so i'm just going out to fact the
assistant coach coach ray he's seeing me
and i'm going out to fact like i think
i'm nice so you're gonna have to you
know i'm saying you have to respect it
out of the way
yeah so i'm going in yeah i'm saying
like
and then back home things just started
the it felt like crumble like whenever
you're not around
and you're not there to see things
happen you're just hearing it from afar
it feels like everything's going bad i
started having
now i'm saying deaths in the family and
stuff like and everything's hitting me
way harder whenever i'm
you know miles away from my family so it
was tough for sure but
it's crazy like i wanted to go home so
bad i'm steady calling my mom's like mom
just let me come home
please just look like i'm i'm begging
her to let me slide back to the crib but
yeah it's crazy how much it helped me
and i'm glad i did it for sure and
going into college was so much easier
because i was already used to being
you know on my own and and trying to
make things happen for myself
clearly like arlen's saying your
hometown meant a lot to you so like what
how did it also shape you as just who
you are escade
that's where everybody's at it's and
what's crazy
it's not even as much about like you
know
missing home but it's missing home
and then trying to still get in the gym
every day and put your work in and still
be first in every sprint and still you
know what i'm saying like that's
that's the part that's tough for guys
whenever they get out to my bird or
whatever is
you know that separation gets tough and
then whenever things get hard for you
and you
see some adversity no you start missing
home that's whenever you usually get to
be at the crib and and take some time
off but
you know you're gone you're at my
birthday you can't you don't really have
it so
you know i i didn't realize how much i
needed arlington
until i left and then i'm like that's
why that's everything it took me so
yeah it shaped me man maybe who i am
today i'm born and raised over there so
yeah home for sure so what i want to
know is
your mentality with uh picking in the
spots
and and taking over games what is kate's
mentality with
taking over games for me every game i'm
trying to eat you know i'm saying like
obviously i'm going into every game one
in 50 or whatever
but obviously game plans things like
that
it's not it's not as easy as that so i
know i'm gonna leave my mark on every
game
and like that like i go into every game
knowing that's a given like i'm gonna do
something like i'm saying other team
gonna know
why they say what they say about me and
and every game it just felt like the
first half was slip away
from me a little bit like i'm trying to
make things happen or whatever
and the first half was slipped and i'm
like i got to do some work in a second
every time and there were some games
where you know things were
going easy for me in the first half or
whatever but
yeah it was yeah i wish i would turn up
a little bit more and then and then the
narrative started going whatever
you know he only told him in the second
half so you know how i go
but yeah yeah how did that approach
like get so instilled in you with like
doing what it takes to win because it's
hard
it's like sometimes like you said you
might be off but you know when to take
over the game
sometimes you might be flowing you got
to know when to pick your spots and
everything but to win the ball game you
have to do a lot of things to win
so like how did you get to that point i
think the big
i think the main like beginning for me
was the
texas titans um i started playing with
in the fourth grade
so like now i'm saying we're we're
young when we started this and then
we're winning games
uh and we were tough like we're
nationals we're we're doing all the
stuff that you know i'm saying these
young teams are going whatever
and you know i think the biggest thing
for us was our togetherness like
everybody knew like the titans their
chemistry was on point
no matter what they gonna make plays for
each other like they're gonna get good
shots
maybe they might not hit them but
they're gonna make sure they get each
other good shots
yeah and so playing in a system like
that since i was a youngin
and then growing up into that and then i
started getting better and better and
better
like i was still used to playing that
type of basketball so
um eventually it just carried over i
guess it leads into
um you with your leadership as well
because they also say that about you
everywhere you've been was mountain bird
and or even you know oklahoma state um
and even some of your edu teammates is
always about
like he always has a control
over the game and like a cop and they
listen to you right so when you speak a
lot of your teammates will make sure
they trust you so you think that also
has something to do with that
like how comfortable you are with
leadership yeah definitely
definitely and i think i think that
mainly helps me with like whenever i'm
new to a room
i don't i don't ever feel like you know
a room sways me into
you know going with the the majority i
feel like that's that's the main thing
that
my parents have you know really
instilled in me and then
after a while whenever my name started
to blow up and things like that
um i think the most important thing was
just not trying to force things on
like i feel like a lot of times you know
somebody might be the most known or the
best player and they try to force
leadership on guys and stuff like that
and it's not like a lot of times dudes
are like bro you just doing too much
trying to
you know i'm
i try to be me wherever i'm at and you
know i
i know i can hoop so in practice you
have to see me anyway
so i think as time goes on people just
you know naturally start to gravitate
towards me and
you know i try to do a better squad i
got my thoughts too but
i think that's why not you know trying
to force leadership
helps because whenever i make a mistake
you're not gonna wanna
bash me for it you're gonna wanna help
me just like i wanna help you so
i think that's probably the main thing i
think that's why my team has been pretty
good
did some of that have to do with just
the 2020 class in itself
like because of how um talented
that you know that at least we view it
and i view it as as deep as it goes
you think somebody also had to do with
your class you were in as well
definitely i think we i'm so glad that
i'm in
the 2020 class is because of the way
that we pushed each other like
and camps um you know everything we just
we pushed each other to a different
level that
like we were friendly with each other we
had fun done up but
i think you can ask anybody that ran
camps
with us or anything i we never whenever
you know saying we were scrimmaging or
or whatever we never played friendly
like we were always pushing each other
we always competed
and i think that's that's why you know
we've at the 2020 class we all went to
college we performed well
you know i'm saying people are people
excited to see what we do at the next
level just because
like we've been competing hard for a
long time so
it's carrying over like those things
don't happen by accident the aspirations
um along this whole journey right you've
had them but now
being this close to like what is the nba
player that you're
hoping to become the best
i'm trying to be that dude i want to be
the best
point guard if they list me as a point
guard of all time the best whatever you
want to call it
um yeah i want to be him like i want
will never
dudes think of nba they think
cunningham is yeah one of them so yeah
yeah and i'm excited for it i think the
biggest thing is like
you know i've already went through the
high school thing of college thing
that's like the you know the amateur
you know amateur basketball whatever and
being able to see myself next to number
one ranked or you know i'm saying
whatever was cool but
now that you know i'm saying i really
get to to play against dudes that i
didn't you know idolize growing up or
you know just been studying their games
or whatever having been able to compete
against them
i'm excited it's going to be fun for
sure and then and then
now my name is i hop into this league my
name is
is like it's hot but it's there's
nothing compared to some of these dudes
so
you're not really turning up you feel me
so it's lit yeah no that's for sure